welcome everyone as I think you all know
today is a dissertation defense and
Steve Williamson will be defending they
work that he's been doing for quite some
time and he will follow the usual
protocol for dissertation and thesis
defenses where the candidate will
present their work there will be kind of
public questioning then all but the exam
committee in the candidate will be
dismissed and the exam committee will
ask a few more questions whatever they
would like and then the candidate is
dismissed and the committee will render
their final verdict on successful or
unsuccessful defense anyways um an XE
before i start with steve i just want to
remind everyone that this is a pretty
packed week but everyone is encouraged
to come to all the presentations patty
yao will be defending her dissertation
tomorrow morning at ten a.m. and then at
noon we have an outside speaker I know
it's a lot for one day but he's passing
through town a colleague of mine dr.
Steve lab cop who has a lot of work in
has done a lot of work in informatics
and the pharmaceutical industry and I
think most people will find his talk
interesting he works for intelligent
medical objects now which is a
terminology company anyway so I hope to
see everyone at both those talks
tomorrow so back to Steve this is his
fifth year as a PhD student he has been
a fixture around the department been on
the NLM training grant he came to us
after receiving his bachelor's degree in
computer information technology from
Brigham Young university-idaho and he's
focused his
graduate work on mobile applications in
consumer health and he's going to
present to us today on working with
family caregivers of older adults so all
yours Phil thanks everyone for being
here it's it's a big day for me and I
appreciate y'all being here so
everything that I'm going to talk to you
today about is about people and I really
like that about my work it's about how
do we help people how do we understand
people and and you know I've titled this
the user centered design of mobile apps
for distance caregivers of older adults
that live in a smart home environment
and I wanted to kind of start by taking
a step back back a long time ago this is
to about 400 BC the Confucian philosophy
of filial piety what does that mean it
means respecting one's elders and you
know that was you know depicted way back
then and this idea of how do we care for
our older adults in our society is
nothing new but the challenges that come
with that are changing so you know one
way you can look at this is through use
of what they call population pyramids
this idea that you can get a bar graph
this is male and female of the
population distribution over the
different age groups and back in
nineteen eighty you can see we have
somewhat of a pyramid shape with an
extra sort of boom right here that you
can see but let's see what happens over
time so in 2010 we you know about right
now we have more of this square in kind
of shape but when we look at the
projection for 20-40 especially look at
what happens in these age groups right
here that there's this almost doubling
and a lot of
if you go back and forth between those
two age groups and you know this is
called population ageing and it's
something that's not just here in the
United States fact in many other
countries that's even more obvious that
it's going to happen and is happening
and so what does that mean in healthcare
well on this side we have the number of
enrollees and Medicare the largest way
that people receive medical care as they
age and we see that you know there's
going to be almost the doubling and the
number of people that enroll in Medicare
and then even more significantly the
difference in cost per person is also
going to close the double and so you
know how do we minimize some of this
increase because we have kind of the
double effect here of increased
enrollees and increased costs part of
the problem is you know this is an
article that pop up on CNN just a couple
days ago really in May and this idea of
elder orphans that more and more older
adults through various circumstances
whether it's that their children don't
live close by maybe they never had
children their children have died for
whatever reason they are orphans as
older adults and they said that
approximately you know because one-third
of Americans and the younger categories
are single that we're really going to
have an increased problem with this idea
of older though orphans as well and we
don't have enough care facilities to
take care of all these people and the
research agrees you know with the common
media which you know happens every once
awhile and and yes of Ryan at all and
I'll you know projected this a few years
ago as well that we're going to have
more and more people that don't live
with the spouse or don't live with the
child nearby look at these huge
increases in just 20 years especially
over here and so the problem is you know
let's review number one we have more
older adults in general number two it's
going to cost more to take care of these
people that's coming number three we
have fewer family members to take care
of these people and so how can
informatics play a role in this how can
we come in well one way we can do this
is through looking at family caregivers
family caregivers our friends and family
members that provide unpaid care to
older adults and there's about 34
million caregivers throughout the United
States and on average they provide about
20 hours of tear I love this number if
we paid them all ten dollars an hour
we'd have to give them almost 500
billion dollars every single year which
is you know that's significant that's
fifteen percent of all the money we
spend on healthcare every year we would
have to pay just to them and so the IOM
Institute of Medicine you know called it
the backbone of much of the care that's
received in the United States is
provided by these caregivers so in
informatics you know we love to use
technology and we love people and so the
whole idea is the central theorem of our
whole field is that a person plus a
computing device is better than just a
person by themselves that there's some
sort of augmentation that happens
through combining technology with people
and often we talk about that in the case
of a physician but today we're going to
talk about that in the case of a
caregiver how can we augment caregivers
and help them to provide better care and
we went to the research and honestly
there's not a lot of information about
how to do this element so that was where
we started our search
one way you could do this though is
through the Ken there's been a recent
explosion of what they call smart homes
and these homes have different sort of
sensors where we can look at things like
socialization medication vital signs
cognition you know blood glucose levels
goals activities and sleep and we have
all these different sensors that can
measure all these sorts of different
things for the older adult and then you
know possibly feed that information back
to a caregiver and there's been you know
some effort to do that I'll let you
guess which one is industry and which
one is academia and we kind of have this
interesting juxtaposition we're on the
industry side you know there's some good
design going on but there's no real
research to back up the validity and the
effectiveness of these tools on the
research side we are seeing more of that
work but there's very little design or
saving place one thing we really did
find in the research so far though is a
lot of questions and you know there's a
whole bunch of different ones i pulled
out here and you don't have to read
every single one but i think the
important part here is number one the
things that are highlighted in color
here those are kind of the the types of
information and the questions we're
going to ask but also like I said this
talk is about people and every single
one of these questions involves
caregivers in one way or another and so
to answer these questions we need to
understand this group more specifically
and more deeply and I really like this
quote you know we have academia we have
industry and this idea that good design
is really a combination of science and
art that's where they break even and
that we really can apply science to
design as end and find this kind of good
match between the left and right
so one way we can do that is through
something called user centered design
and I really like this quote that user
centered design means understanding what
your users need how they think and how
they behave and then incorporating that
understanding into every aspect of your
process and these three words that I
have highlighted here those are going to
kind of be our guiding principles as we
go through and talk about the different
work that I've done and we'll see here
that you know the first study we looked
at users needs and we did a needs
assessment where we were able to go
through and and talk to caregivers and
have open discussions with them about
what were their needs the second phrase
was we want to understand how people
behaved and one way to do that was
through usability research where we
could provide them with a tool and see
how they interacted with them how they
behaved and then finally within that
tool we really want to understand how
that tool caused them to think and how
they were able to understand that tool
and this idea that we can understand the
insight that they can gain from charts
and figures within a tool so let's dive
right in we'll kind of go through each
of these sets the first step we really
want to understand caregiver needs and
we started with you know the things here
we talked to people we talked to experts
we looked in the research we looked at
what had been done commercially and we
fed that all into an interview process
that then helped us to understand
caregiver needs and here at ohsu we're
very lucky we have access to what we
call the architect Living Lab which is a
group of older adults that live in their
own homes and they live in these smart
homes that I was talking about and they
are able to live independently and then
we monitor them and we use this as kind
of a test platform to look at do
for technologies to promote healthy
aging and so we measure things like
their sleep how are they how we provide
them with cognitive exercises how much
social interaction are they getting are
they physically active and one of those
in interventions the socialization
intervention required them to talk with
someone of their family members on a
regular basis and so we were able to use
these family members that we already had
recruited and then bring them into our
needs assessment study and so we were
able to talk to 10 of them now and since
they were all over America we use Skype
to do that we Skyped with them and then
we used what we called stimulus
materials this idea that we provided
them with prototypes and mock-ups to
help elicit more feedback but first of
all we ask them these very basic
questions you know what information
would help you care for your older adult
remotely and then how could a computer
to lure website help you and we just let
them talk and we listened and we
recorded what they said and we really
tried to just open ended Lee allow them
to provide information what would be
useful to them at that point we then I
like this quote you have to feed forward
if you want feedback and so we fed it
forward by providing some stimulus
materials and through providing them
with some sort of a mock-up and it was
something like this we presented over
PowerPoint over Skype and you know just
some basic similar interactive screen
shots and then were able to get their
feedback and elicit even further
discussion and and results from them so
like I said were recorded them then we
transcribed and coded them and then sort
of try to categorize and make sense of
it all so what are some of the
information is that they talked about
well there's a lot of them and I don't
want to talk about all of them because I
have enough time but
few of them that were important number
one this idea of a shared calendar
between the older adult and the
caregiver and maybe even multiple
caregivers and this idea that we can
collaborate and coordinate care through
the use of a calendar everybody I talked
to talk about the importance of
medication and they really wanted to be
able to understand if pill boxes were
properly filled and if older adults were
adhering to the medication regimen that
had been prescribed to them people
really were interested in cognitive help
I think there's a lot of fear about
cognitive decline in older age and so
caregivers really want to be able to
understand that more deeply and they
really want to be able to track it over
time as well this idea that it's really
important to track that kind of
information longitudinally instead of
just having small snapshots and then of
course they wanted intelligent alerts
that if there was a problem they wanted
to be told there was a problem they
didn't want to always have to be
checking to land and you know go in and
always find out but they wanted to have
an alert when it was necessary and then
they also this idea of how can i help my
loved one they wanted some feedback and
guidance they want to know if they were
doing well they wanted to know what they
could change that sort of thing so those
are the information needs but we also
came up with some design needs that go
along with that we talked about we
talked about how they would use some
sort of a tool you know how often would
they use at that sort of thing and a lot
of people said they would use it you
know half of the people said they would
use it more than once a week with quite
a few people using it multiple times a
week and they talked about this sort of
in and out usage where it was a quick in
quick out and so you know how can we
design a tool to fit that usage pattern
while it needs to be informative it
needs to be understandable some sort of
a dashboard perhaps it needs to be
really easy
stand and they really talked about how
if you're going to alert me you know it
better be a real deal a better not just
be a small little change or something a
better be important and so we need to be
conservative about that some of the
other things we've asked them you know
what sort of device would you use well
they said when I'm on the go I'll use a
smartphone I'll use an iPad but when I
come back home I want to go to use it on
my computer as well and so this idea I
like this picture this idea that we can
use an application the program on
multiple different devices and it
behaves similarly across devices and we
can kind of hybridize where the
application lives and it's less
important about which devices song and
then one other thing we found two is
that most people on the on their
smartphones already had a calendar so
they didn't want another one and this
idea that we shouldn't reproduce things
that people already have which seems
obvious but you know we do it all the
time if you look at a lot of the other
things that are done I'm and the final
thing here this idea that older adults
or the caregivers felt that the older
adults would really want to have control
over who saw the data and be able to
turn it off and and to caregivers that
was an important feature even though it
wasn't their data this idea that when we
do provide logic to terminal data we
really need to find a way to mitigate
noise was something that they talked
about and they want to be able to
provide personalized thresholds for
older adults depending on the condition
and and their health concerns at the
time and then this one was interesting
to this idea that most of the people we
talked to didn't I didn't identify as
caregivers themselves they said oh here
you were someone who provides hands-on
care and so we had to you know think how
does that influence our design that we
can't necessarily
further these people as caregivers when
we're talking to them because they might
think that somebody else instead of
themselves so you know this was our
needs assessment and this is how we
started to understand needs and you know
what are some of the criticisms all we
talked to 10 people so you know that is
a fairly small sample and people knew
that I was directly tied to this working
and because of that often people may be
hesitant to criticize and then in the
words of Steve Jobs people don't
necessarily know what they mean and you
know that's a definite consideration
when when we think about our findings
from this work so that's the first study
so we took these needs and we built a
prototype we build a fully interactive
prototype this time and then we were
able to go into usability testing where
we were able to let caregivers actually
use the tool and then after we analyzed
the results than those findings we fed
back into our prototype and we do
iterative testing over multiple cycles
to improve the usability of our
prototype and so we're going to go
through each of those stages you know
what does the interactive prototype look
like well something like this this was
you know one of the graph springs and
this is kind of the home screen for the
application and after we built that we
built that in the tool called just in
mind which is a prototype builder that
uses HTML and JavaScript and we then
went into usability testing where we
were able to actually start to see how
people interact with this and so we had
five different scenarios that were based
on you know the most typical tasks and
activities that we thought
do within the app and we asked them to
follow these tasks and then to think
aloud and the idea is you know you just
say what you're thinking as you go but
more importantly than what they said we
were concerned with what they were doing
and so a lot of observation went into
this as well and then finally at the end
after usability testing then we had
debriefing interviews where we were able
to you know ask them why they did things
what was going through your head when
you did this where do we did that and
then to analyze we we developed a fairly
novel approach to actually analyzing the
results so we went through and we
actually listed each of the problems
that we found and then we threw them
into three separate categories and the
whole idea here is we were trying to be
very operational very quick and so we
either said well number one we don't
understand this well enough and we need
to keep going in the next round of
testing the better understand this issue
or we came up with a solution and then
in the next round if we had implemented
a solution we then tried to see if we
had actually fixed that specific problem
and so you know you see some of the
different issues here and how we were
able to resolve them over multiple
rounds of testing and design and then
like I said we fed that information back
into the prototype and improved it over
time so you know why why do you do this
why do you do multiple rounds and why
why not just do testing with 15 or 20
people with one round well this is based
on the work of Nielsen which if you look
over here as you increase the number of
people in your test the you find out
less and less information per person and
so if you look right at about five users
you find out about eighty percent of the
usability problems from the first five
users and your tab
and so you know the idea here is you
find out most problems and then you fix
those and then we were able to kind of
take care of the low-hanging fruit first
and so we did that by number one our
first round that we use usability
students I mean so basically it was
people here in the department and people
that had taken some classes and
usability and were able to find a lot of
the issues that that were in the
application and the reason we did that
was because we wanted to have the most
authentic version of the prototype for
our most authentic test subjects and so
we're able to do that across the three
different rounds and keep this kind of
operational rapid approach throughout
the whole thing so you know what did we
find out well if you look at the total
number of problems for each round and
then the newly identified problems for
each round you see that you know some of
some issues came up here that we're also
in this round and the point is though
that over time the number of issues goes
down and especially the number of new
issues goes down significantly so what
are what were some of the issues well
there was a lot of kind of at specific
tweaks that we talked about so for
example this was a legend for a graph
and to be able to see the different
colors in the graph we had to be able to
discern through these between these
three different colors and they really
said well that needs to be bigger so we
changed them two squares just basic
things over here if you look on your
smartphone though there's often a little
circle with some sort of a badge or
notification but you probably haven't
seen one of these before where there's a
check mark saying there's everything
that's okay because the way that's
communicated is generally through the
absence of any sort of a badge and so
people told us that we need to you know
that's actually confusing to tell us
it's okay we'd rather see nothing there
a third one was people wanted to click
on the word zoom
rather than realize it was just a label
and they also were confused by these
abbreviations this idea 1am to them at
one minute when we were going for one
month and then the height of the buttons
we change to just a lot of very small
but significant things that we wouldn't
have realized if we hadn't gone through
this process what are some kind of
larger scale things that we learned
though well one thing this idea of data
is stacking so if you look right here a
lot of people in our study said okay the
number of outgoing minutes is you know
what is that about 45 maybe when you
actually look at the little legend that
pops up though it was actually 37 and
the idea here is that these two series
are actually meant to be stacked on top
of each other and that was really
confusing to a lot of people
interestingly though if you do that with
a bar graph people were able to
understand it without any problems and
so you know one of the things we really
learned from this is the importance of
of not stacking axes like this or you
know stacking different series of data
and some sort of a line graph but that
it isn't appropriate as a bar graph the
other thing that really came out was the
difficulty of conveying images of
medications and so the idea here if you
see version 1 is that this is an image
of the pill box at the day before or
early in the day so you know yesterday
and then the today this pill box is
empty and the users task is then to say
well you know if I look up here
yesterday there were pills and then
today there are not pills which for one
day is appropriate but then these other
two compartments shouldn't be empty and
so people had a really hard time
comparing the top to the bottom image so
we added in version 2 we tried adding
this
yellow box to focus people's attention
um it still didn't work and the
inversion 3 we tried something
completely different where we separated
out images for each and every day and it
still didn't work an inversion for
honestly this is the the design we're at
right now but the problem is we only had
three rounds of usability testing and we
still don't know if it works but we have
some data from previous France that
suggests that it might and so you know
one of the important take homes from
this is that rather than thinking about
usability testing is okay I need to do
three rounds we really need to think
about it as we need to do two additional
rounds after any significant redesign
which i think is a more intelligent way
of thinking about it rather than just
the generic three times so what are some
of the limitations of this well you know
a third of our subjects for caregivers
but that's also a strength in a way
because it allowed us to be more nimble
in the way we conducted our testing the
same thing goes for the fact that we
didn't do any audio or video recording
we could have done that and it probably
would have added to the scientific rigor
but it also would have been a much
slower cumbersome process and we really
want to be more more agile than that
this was done in the lab setting and
then there are you know multiple papers
that are documenting this idea of an
evaluator effect that when you are doing
think aloud usability testing it's
highly dependent on the skills of the
researcher doing it doing the work so we
had this this mobile app and we had a
prototype but we still didn't really
understand what we were communicating to
people we prevent presented them with
charts and figures we knew that they
could kind of navigate through them but
we didn't understand if they were
actually able to discern if there was a
problem and actually understand some of
what was going on and you know so this
is the progression from start to finish
up from the usability testing
and so that it's this idea that the tool
was usable but it's not necessarily
insightful and so how can we look at the
insight that that is communicated and
how can we measure the value of the
different charts and figures within the
graph I mean within that and so to do
this there's a couple different ways to
do this and so one way to do this is
through what they call Vince benchmark
based evaluation where basically you
present a chart and figure something
like this and you know which and then
you ask a question so which hamburger
topping is preferred by the most NLM
fellows and you know if you answer
lettuce then great you get a prize and
otherwise you you fail and but basically
looking at how what's the rate of
correct versus incorrect at when you ask
a question about a visualization but
there's some problems with doing it this
way number one it requires very specific
questions that have very specific
answers the second part of this is that
it's not at all realistic of what
happens in the real world because the
questions are actually leading the user
to an answer whereas if you actually
just provide a charter or figure to
someone without as some sort of a
question they don't necessarily know
what they're looking for and so there's
another way to do this called insight
based evaluation and it was originally
developed and talked about in the
bioinformatics world by soraya at all in
2005 and we sort of adopted this method
and and tweaked it a little bit for our
purposes and the whole idea behind this
methodology is that the principal
purpose of some sort of data
representation is to elicit insight that
you know the data representation then
leads to this knowledge or insight and
what is an insight but it's an
individual observation about the data by
the participant or a unit of discovery
and each insight has characteristics
things like what is the actual
observation how much time did it take to
arrive at that observation is a correct
or not you know might be a great insight
but it might be completely wrong what
value do we assign to that insight and
then does it generate the hypothesis and
lead to further questions or not and so
too you know we actually developed ten
different scenarios that we were then
we're going to go on and test with this
insight faith based methodology and
those ten scenarios we put into two
general bins either simple charts with
122 graphical features moderate charts
or three to four or complex with 55 or
more and we tried to you know I think we
did for these three of these and three
of these and then you know we had a
whole protocol that we asked caregivers
to go through the first was we used what
a validated survey instrument called the
graph literacy scale which is basically
designed to measure subjects ability to
understand and interpret health-related
charts and figures after that we then
had a training phase where we were able
to train people in the idea of thinking
aloud as they discover different parts
of a visualization on and also train
them on how to actually navigate and use
the charts and figures because we didn't
want the learning curve to affect their
ability to actually understand these and
so we did that by talking to them and
then also providing them with a sandbox
environment to actually go in and
explore a little bit and then we
actually did this main insight study
where we asked participants to go in and
open and lee explore each of these
scenarios and when they were ready to
move on to the next one they were
allowed to and then we recorded what
they said their audio their voice as we
did that
and then part of that is we then were
able to go in and try and rank the
different types of insight and so this
rubric is a combination of a few
different things that the first three
items in our classification came
directly from the graph literacy scale
this idea can you read a value that's
directly on the chart the second is we
can read between the data can you
identify patterns and trends can you
read beyond the data it's the idea of
extrapolating beyond data and then these
next three we actually incorporated from
psoriasis or where this idea can you
read beyond the specific graph you're
looking at and can you see how that
graph ties back to a different graph
you've already seen and then did the
data lead to some sort of hypotheses
hypothesis generation and then we assign
the highest score to this idea of acting
on the data that the ultimate goal this
app was to help people to action when
there was a problem and so when people
identify the problem and said what they
were going to do about it that's when we
provided the highest score after we did
that then we can kind of see back here
we had laminated the printouts of each
of the representations you sort of the
graphs and we just had them sort them
out on the table from least useful the
most OOP most useful and and just kind
of get an idea in their head about the
utility of each of these charts and
figures and then we had a debriefing
interview where we talked to them and
said okay you know what would you change
what was confusing and then if we if
they did miss something we said well you
know look at this right here how can we
help you see that next time and try to
get even further understanding that way
and then the final step and we had them
complete a too-short questionnaires
called the perceived usefulness and
perceived
ease of use scales and the idea is that
if we are able to measure their
perceived usefulness then that ties back
to our needs assessment that we did up
here that if they find it useful than
we've adequately understood their needs
and if they find it if they perceive it
to be easy to use the net ties back to
our usability work that if a high score
here helps to suggest that our usability
study was able to iron out some of the
usability issues so what did we find out
well you know we purposely slept
selected about two-thirds females versus
males that was you know that's how
caregivers in general or distributed and
we we ended up with a more educated
sample than we had hoped for but we
still did get a good range in education
level we're very happy with the age
range thing that we were able to recruit
right around you know very similar to
tear gamer demographics nationally and
then as some people said we actually
found three people that still don't use
a smartphone but we you know that's
actually fairly similar to national data
as well so how did we do in terms of
graph literacy well the national average
is about nine point or is nine point
three and we came in a little bit high
at about ten point seven and that was
significantly higher than the national
average and then the perceived ease of
use and usefulness scales we scored you
know five point eight and six on the
scale from one to seven and so we felt
very good about that and that those
scores are actually very favorable when
compared to other caregiving tools that
have used these same scales to try and
measure ease of use and usefulness
then this is interesting as well as that
there was a significant correlation
between people that perceive the tool is
useful and then the insight score that
we go on to assign based on the insights
but that they could elicit from the
graphs so this is there's a lot of data
in this chart so just kind of take your
time to go through it a little bit so
you know we had the three different
levels of complexity in the graphs and
then if you look for either asterisks or
an ass that's where there's a
significant difference amongst the
categories so if you see you know in the
number of insights there was a
significant difference you know both
between the simple and the moderate and
the simple and complex between the
number of insights that could be
elicited which you know might agree with
with what you would think but the
difference between modern complex is
actually very small and was not
significantly different and so then the
insight value we saw a difference
between the complex and the simple but
not between the complex and moderate and
then this idea of insight rate the idea
that when you're using a smartphone app
especially that the amount of insight
that you can communicate in the first 30
seconds as a critically important and so
we looked at the rate of insight and
found that you know this is really
interesting here that the moderate
graphs were actually outperformed the
complex ones and we're significantly
different than the simple ones and we'll
talk a little bit more about that later
in terms of number of errors there was a
significant difference between those as
well but not in the number of undirected
errors which is interesting and then the
other significant difference we've had
was then the number of calls to action
between the three different charts so
you know
let's explore this a little bit more so
one of the things we can do is we can
look at the insights gained over time
for the different charts and graphs and
I know you don't know what each of these
are but there are a few I want to point
out this one right here you know it's
kind of way below the pack and people
hated that one not just in terms of the
number of insights but then in the card
sort it was routinely right at the
bottom had lots of things that people
want to say about it and it was
interesting to see how you know that all
aligns that that boasts an hour in site
evaluation and in our other data we
collected it all matched up this orange
one right here is interesting just
because it's so much shorter than the
rest and that's significant because
people didn't want to spend as much time
looking at that one the reason why is
because some of the data in that chart
actually closely mirrored one of the
other charts and they were both looking
at physical exercise but from two
different measures and so since people
had already seen the one they didn't
feel they knew to explore the second one
as much and then the other thing I want
to point out was this one up here that
this one's kind of like the gift that
keeps on giving that you know when the
rest of them started to taper out it
starts to and then for some reason there
is more information to be found in that
one so you know if we look at just the
three complexity levels this is what it
looks like and you definitely see this
you know that the low complexity really
tapers out sooner than the rest that the
amount of information people can get
really diminishes much more quickly the
other two are more similar but the high
complexity you know does provide a
little more information if you are
willing to wait you know almost two
minutes or you know a minute 45 let's
look at the the first 30 seconds because
you know that's so you know that zoomed
in
then here's the cleaned-up version so I
think this is a really interesting chart
because it points out this idea that
over the first 30 seconds the medium
complexity may you know in general we
don't know but in our findings at least
may outperform the high complexity and
you know what are the reasons for that
well we're not sure but it may be that
the cognitive load of a high complexity
graph that actually takes longer to kind
of get to grips with and so you know I
think this is a really interesting
finding that that would really be
interesting to go in and do some further
exploration with so some of the other
things we found you know through talking
to people and that sort of thing and
then through the card sort was this idea
of the importance of zoom that people
were very good at finding an issue or
find our eliciting an insight if they
were actually willing to go up here and
look at the right zoom level but the
problem was some people skipped right
past it and missed it and so one of the
things that I think would really help
future system design would be the idea
that if we were able to intelligently
know which zoom level to display based
on the current data that we're
displaying that would really help users
to be able to actually find the issue we
don't need to know what the issue is we
don't need to be able to tell them how
to behave or anything else but we just
need to be able to get them to the right
screen basically and you know this is a
good indication of that if that you if
you look just at the one week for you
and then you look at the six month view
the the picture you that you and the
conclusions you draw are significantly
different between those two one of the
other things so we purposely designed
some in congruence in in this room
visualization with the top
part showing that you know about two of
the four goals have been met this week
but then if you look down here you know
there at what ten percent of the goal
completion nobody well one person was
able to detect that in congruence and so
we felt that meant that there was a lot
of high or high level of trust in the
system and I think it's really important
that as part of that we maybe have some
algorithms or something to check for
congruence between the you know
especially in the dashboard view where
you might be presenting three or four
different charts to make sure they
actually agree with each other because
users were not good at that so this is
the one everyone hated maybe you hate it
too but you know what's interesting was
that these non-traditional charts we had
to reorient in general they actually
elicited more and higher-quality
insights than the more typical line and
larger bar graphs but it also we had
this polar reaction where most people
hated this and two people loved it two
people rated as the highest and so you
know the idea here is if you're going to
use something that's a little less
traditional you should probably have
extra testing to make sure it's as good
as you think it is and and you know it
eat a piece of humble pie along the way
so what were some of the limitations of
this well there was a definitely a
chance to order bias in the fact that we
didn't randomize the order that the the
representations were did that or were
displayed to people and going along with
that there's that may be a technique
learning effect that people be got
better at the think aloud process as
time went on so we really recommend that
anyone out to follow this methodology
would would randomize the order and you
know our sample is certainly more
graphically literate and educated than
the general population which may have
influenced their ability to
and interpret and understand charts and
figures and then you know this is our
first step to understanding this in
insight based methodology and so we
really need further work to go in and
validate if we're measuring what we
think we're measuring when it comes to
insight and then the idea that our way
that we were able to go in the determine
graph complexity will be looking at
graphical features and the number of
graphical features is probably a fairly
simplified approach to that but there's
there's a lot of other things that go
into determining how complex a charter
figure is and we'd love to go in and
look at that a little more in detail as
well so you know how you know if we look
at these three different steps that
we've gone through how does this
contribute to science well it definitely
gives us a fuller and better
understanding of caregiver needs and and
the needs assessment we were able to
present at a meal last year for the
behaved section you know this idea of
operational usability is kind of a new
methodology that we you know adapted
from from previous work and being nimble
and being able to do that quickly and
tentatively that's going to be published
in Jamie I soon and and then this idea
that we were able to take a relatively
new methodology and extend it beyond
just being used with scientists in the
past it was only done with scientists
and to be able to do that with
non-scientists and then go in and
understand a little bit about how they
think is I think adds a lot to this
process I'm and then each step of the
way we would had design implications and
lessons learned that that really we
believe will help contribute to this
problem of how do we take care of our
older adults in the famous words of
Gandhi a nation's greatness is measured
by how it treats its weakest
members and I really believe that that
this work can help to do that as we work
to take care of older adults and and
help them age in place successfully and
with that I'd like to help the Kazon
their own way to thank a lot of people
first and foremost Holly and Paul thank
you thank you for your mentoring your
advice for genuinely caring and then the
rest of my committee Paula on the phone
Michelle and Vishnu thank you for your
invaluable expertise advice and
mentorship and then you know so many
people in this room that have been a
part of this journey for me you know
andrea lynn then you know that i didn't
even want to put names up here because I
i knew i'd forget somebody but but thank
you I really do appreciate it of course
I want to acknowledge the NLM training
grant that helped to fund this work
along the way and then last and
certainly not least my wonderful parents
and my beautiful wife for putting up
with me and the long nights and and
everything else along the way and with
that I'd love to hear some of your
questions
oh and if you do have a question
remember to push the button
alright so a simple question then do
this over again is there any major thing
you do differently to be back that's a
good question very thought-provoking
question two um yes there are some
things I'd do differently I think one
really simple thing I could have done in
the inside study the final study would
have just been to randomize the order
that things were present I think that
would have been a very simple change
that would have would have helped to
eliminate some of the bias in that study
I think another thing I might have done
when you're doing usability testing
there's this trade-off between do I
build a really rich interactive
experience or do I build a much simpler
sort of what they call wireframe and you
know if you provide a rich interactive
experience that's more authentic but it
also you kind of have to decide on a
design direction and decide on things
kind of prematurely almost and so I
think it would have been interesting
that maybe you know as you go through
the rounds of usability testing to
become more and more authentic in terms
of prototype fidelity as well and I
think that you know that would have
maybe been a little more work but I
think it would have helped us to not get
so solidly in a design direction too
soon does that make sense
with the needs assessment um I would
have loved to talk to a few more people
I think I think ultimately you know what
we found out was important but i'm not
sure we reached you know saturation and
i think we could have probably found out
a little bit more than we did thank you
I know technology has been evolving
during the process of as you've been
developing this over the last few years
but as we start to look the smartphones
are starting to look small in comparison
to the tablets that we start seeing to
the room what do you think the proper
medium will be for this that's a really
good question um and you know we talked
a little bit about that when we talked
about the needs assessment this idea of
hybrid usage across the different form
factors I think ultimately the
portability and we always connect the
nature of a smartphone is ideal simply
because it provides a good mechanism for
alerting when there is a problem let you
know if you want to find out if there's
a problem you don't want to wait till
you get home that day but this idea also
that you know you could alert across
different devices and whatever one you
pick up first the alert is there and
getting away is almost like device
independence in a way I think is
probably how I see this going
if I were to give you a grant for a
million dollars right now how would you
follow up on this work what would you do
with it what are the priorities I would
love to do an intervention study and
actually built this thing and see if I
you know one thing we didn't look at it
was well people actually use this in her
world and you know that's important that
there's a lot of a lot of applications
that get built that might you know
someone might tinker with it for a few
days and then put it down and after that
it's just annoying and they don't touch
it again and I'd love to be able to look
at you know if we really built this
thing with real data about your loved
one number one do you care like is that
something you're going to use and number
two how does that change the care that
you provide and I'd love to be able to
do that if we had the time and money to
do it yeah so actually maybe you might
want to spend some of the money on this
too I was interested in the the you
noted that a limitation was the
educational level of people you know
which is always an issue with you know
technology you know as academics you
know we tend to develop it and then you
know test it on on people who don't you
know represent the normal population how
how might you sort of delve further into
that question and and what you know what
might you do you know to try to
accommodate you know people who you know
a lower educational level and maybe
having more difficulty using it so
that's really interesting and important
question I think one way that we could
try and address that more as you know
obviously we from a study perspective
being able to sample more people and get
at that lower segment a little more
but from an application and design
perspective to this idea that you know
maybe you could have tailored
information based on your ability to
understand different types of charts and
figures that you know if there was some
sort of very quick way of understanding
a person's graphical literacy then you
could change the complexity of the
graphs accordingly and I think that
would be a great way to do it if you
could convince people to take a you know
a quick little introduction survey at
the beginning or something having said
that you know I don't know if that would
offend people or anything else they
don't have to know but but I think it
could provide extra value if you took
that sort of an approach
oh I got what you said the average
number of insights you got / graph for
the last part it's um but I was
wondering if you had a sense of how many
like how many people actually got the
insights that they should have gotten or
how many were off if you can just give
it kind of a feel for what an overview
what you observe yeah so that it goes
kind of back to to this one that as long
as people were at the right zoom level
thank you know it you know most of these
graphs not all of them some of them were
just boring but a lot of them had a
take-home message and you know that's
really important do it if you missed the
take-home message it doesn't matter
about all the other details you find and
as long as they were at the right kind
of zoom level to see that they were very
good at finding it you know even even
the people that maybe struggled with
some of the exercises often found the
take-home message if they were at the
right sort of zoom I was surprised how
big of a factor you know just clicking
on the different zoom levels would would
be I'd love to hear feedback about ways
to help with that but but no for the
most part people were very good at that
kind of take home message and
identifying it
another question so a lot of this hinges
on the amount of insight performance
insights some prospective value of
insights both in terms of sort of some
insight sorry more garbage than others
but also negative side so it's boring
because no change is that is that count
as an insight they say the novice
surgeon knows how to operate and the
expert another plan and so when you do
nothing that sometimes is a really smart
choice make sure yeah so um if people
were willing to state the obvious we
absolutely gave him credit which you
know basically means if people said oh
yeah you know he's very stable then yes
I absolutely counted as a valuable
insight but the worry is that sometimes
if people see what they consider to be
nothing they won't say it and that is
absolutely a concern of us which we in
when we were doing the the training at
the beginning of this we tried to be
very clear though that you know to ask
them to point out things that were
irregular and things that were more
normal and to describe that describe
them either way so are we sorry when you
were exploring caregiver needs were
there any needs that fell outside the
scope of your app yes yeah absolutely um
you know we had things like people
wanted to be able to track food intake
and so the idea of like a smart
refrigerator and a few things another
person really felt it was important to
have like a hobbies section of the app
yeah absolutely they were worth but you
know most of the time those things were
just mentioned by one person the one
thing that was that came up quite a few
times that we didn't incorporate into
the app was being able to share a
person's medical record with the old
road with the caregiver and as you all
know there are other mechanisms where
we're trying to do that too and
informatics
but didn't feel we need to try and
tackle that as part of the app all right
thanks ever